previously on Mars we at MMC field that  were ready to go faster  phase 2 expansion was underway and the  Cygnus crew had arrived with experts to  oversee upgrades base commander Allison  wait up to add the second facility up by  now but I've been running into trouble  every step of the way  within two months we'll have enough  power to double the size and capacity of  your facilities and I approved this I  informed her yes it's a little too  ambitious right now he'll go to Mars  with that ambition no matter how hard at  Grant's team work to expand Olympus  town's infrastructure Mars worked even  harder to tear it down and I was caught  in the middle trying to keep us alive  our dream is now a reality they don't  know where's I don't see when I get a  chance to get that reactor back  [Music]  [Music]  you